[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
Willian what is it Dom rabbit's here
what Robert says to your left Robert
England hi Robert hello hello thanks for
coming thank you very much well I don't
know you gentlemen you know when when
you invited me I I had this fantasy of
being flown to New Zealand and be
sitting in the Shire you know even worse
case scenario first class flight to
Glasgow and some comfy Pub uh designed
by Renny McIntosh that Billy knew about
but and instead instead I'm out here in
the valley and it's 100 degrees we
didn't even give you a parking spot oh
I'll tell you we'll get there we'll do
the New Zealand trip at some point in
the future exactly I mean we couldn't
believe it when you said yes it's lovely
to have you in the studio thank you very
much we're hoping maybe to have this
particular episode slot in with
Halloween which we were just talking
about off of Cameron holiday is it your
favorite holiday of the year you must be
very popular at parties well it's it's a
lucrative holiday for me
I always get good invitations but it is
it's fun because I think I I think Dom
you were saying it's like Americans are
truly exhibitionists really and that's
their time of year yeah yeah because
where we grew up in Britain it's very
much uh for the kids the kids dress up
when I when I was young in Scotland
you'd have to learn a song or a joke and
then you would round everyone's house
you know trying to get candy or money
but you'd have to do the song that you
learn trick or treat trick or treat yeah
and you would be brought into people's
houses and you'd sing the song and
they'd give you some candy and off you
go in the next house I remember we would
try to go to the to the rich
neighborhoods because the the treats
were better you know you'd get candied
apples you know and and really great
massive chocolate bars and things so did
you grow up in Los Angeles yeah I'm
actually a valley boy uh huh you had to
Peg a canyon for a while and Laurel
Canyon and and Encino yeah right around
I right near your studio I had a seventh
grade girlfriend that broke my heart
right down the street literally on the
same street in front of your studio here
did you think about that as you drove I
did I know it's it's it's the Nostalgia
is incredible around here for me I do a
lot of voice-overs in this neighborhood
and every time I'm out here I just
remember some great birthday party where
somebody taught me how to french kiss or
something oh lovely yeah and so and you
in your lifetime have you noticed
Halloween become a bigger and bigger
thing because certainly in Britain it
went from like Billy said a kind of a
kid's thing to a lot of people are
recognizing it as a legit holiday now
but when I was a kid it was not really
that much of a thing you have Guy Fawkes
Day right yeah yeah that's yeah you
didn't have that so it wasn't replaced
by Halloween but I was surprised when I
first came here how big Halloween is oh
no it's huge I would say the biggest I
would say maybe 20 25 years ago I mean
you guys we've all dealt with with the
effects makeup before and I remember
going to a party I was invited the
hardest party to get into in La was the
special effects makeup man special
invitation party and these guys had
spent all year perfecting uh makeups to
wear and try to outdo each other at
their Halloween party and it was
incredible and I think Kevin Yeager who
did me for a number of The Nightmare on
Elm Street films he went as a like a
cobra head he was like was like a cobra
coming out of human clothing a humanoid
Cobra it was just an incredible makeup
that's brilliant when I was a drama
school we had to we had to do one one
hour a week of makeup and you know you'd
learn how to become an old man or
whatever and then at the end of the year
you had to make up your own one and one
of the guys in my class who had a real
cleft chin he he made his nose uh a
penis
and he made his chin a parable Stone
lovely if you could imagine yeah he
shaved his beard into a and it was quite
an incredible makeup great dick face
takes on a whole new meaning yeah really
but that's I've been lucky enough to
share some great dinners and stuff with
you over the years Robert and many
different countries and I've been so
lucky and I've always thought of you as
that sort of like I didn't know that you
grew up in Italy but you
you are if you don't mind me saying like
an like old Hollywood you know the names
of everyone you've got great stories
about everyone so it felt to me that you
grew up here and and like was your
family involved in in film somewhat you
know I I'm at that age now I'm 76 I'm
going to be 70. and you look fantastic
well but I I straddle a little bit uh
that old Hollywood because it was still
around when I was a child I think we
lived down the street for a while from
Clark Gable and I used to see him at the
at the local market you know in the back
by the Butcher and uh uh there was a
theater literally down the street from
one of my homes and they had the what
they used to call the major Studio
previews there the preview audiences and
my mother and father would be like on a
Tuesday evening or something and they'd
drag little Robbie along with him and it
would be the premiere of King your soul
woman's minds or Anatomy of a Murder
with Jimmy Stewart and they were there
in the audience sometimes you know I
remember seeing The Guns of Navarone you
know and I and you know my generation
World War II was still close enough in
our in our father's memory uh that as as
young boys you know we were preoccupied
with with the war movies of the time of
of World War II and I remember sitting
there and the famous American comedian
Don Knotts from The Andy Griffith Show
was sitting behind us and and I had
loved him because he'd been a one of the
comedy players on the old Steve Allen
Show which was the famous late night
talk show at the time and on the screen
All Through The Guns of Navarone it it
has that military time to let you know
if a clock is ticking as the action
progresses and it would say you know
1400 or or 1300 or something like that
for one o'clock in the morning and Don
knotts's wife would go and Don she gives
me dying what time is it now
and Don Knotts you know would politely
explain to her you know this is now it's
one o'clock you know 13 is one past 12.
it's one one o'clock now and she died
and then you'd be later you know with
Anthony Quinn and Irene Papas and James
Darren and it's a wonderful movie and
the Nazis and and everybody's engrossed
and it would say you know oh 1700 on the
screen and Anthony Quinn was in Jeopardy
and you'd hear that Don and dad what
time is it now this went on halfway
through the movie and and finally my
mother turned around and she went It's
Five O'Clock Mrs knots
Mom
I thought those kind of experiences all
the time I remember surfing and seeing
Lee Marvin on the beach as I walked into
the water you know because out in Malibu
and things like that so it just was a
naturally around you yeah here in
Southern California so was it excuse me
was it being swept up in and around
those you know moments of of seeing
major movie stars and going and seeing
screenings where they might attend was
that the spark for you to be an actor or
what was the thing that got you excited
to want to be an actor I don't think
that was was it I mean I'd love
we'd all love to say we're in it for the
art only and that it was art that that
captured our spirits and at some point
that does become part of uh of our Quest
and our existence as an actor but I was
very young when I began and uh I was
farmed out with a a beautiful young girl
who wanted to be an actress to a teenage
uh Children's Theater and I was at the
very the youngest end of it I was 12.
and I think it went to 18 or 19 and I
thought I was going to be uh uh sweeping
the stage and painting scenery and maybe
being an usher with a flashlight a torch
you know walking about and telling
people where to sit but I did go to the
auditions and I aced it I was Pinocchio
I was Peter Pan I was Hansel you know I
got all the Aladdin you know and I was
12 years old and I was very small all
from my age then I hadn't hit my growth
spurt and
I got that power
of having the lead role in that world
and getting that laugh in the right
place every night night after night that
challenge and how exhilarating that is
it's kind of like being a rock star and
then
the girls and the girls were 12. to 19.
and they were beautiful and they were
older and they taught me how to blow
some smoke rings and I have this memory
of being in the girls bathroom
getting my hair curled for Aladdin my
hair had been dyed black and I had these
little curlers in my hair and the girls
were teaching me how to blow smoke rings
and they were all in by today's
standards really covered them up a lot
but they had put glitter all over their
braziers they were the Harem girls
and they were putting more and more
glitter on the brassiers and
getting my hair to go curly so I'd look
like Aladdin and I think West Side Story
was playing on the record player there
was a portable record player in there
and it echoed around and the girls were
singing songs from West Side Story and
smoke rings and cigarettes and boobs in
my ears you know with glitter on them
and I talked to myself
what and give up show business
I loved it and I was hooked yeah I
remember getting mild hassle from some
of the guys that I used to kick the ball
around with after school where we would
normally go and play football and they
said what are you gonna do
rehearsals for the school play why are
you doing that and I was like it's a
bunch of girls it's like me three guys
yeah and like 35 girls and I love
hanging out with girls and I get an
opportunity to speak to much older girls
because now we're all in the same place
the best girls yeah this is the crazy
actresses
but you know it's true I was a jock I
was a champion swimmer and a gymnast and
I played Little League Baseball but I
remember in high school
going to one of the jock parties and it
was like 30 to one guys versus girls in
terms of the ratio and all the guys were
drunk on a keg of beer yeah and then I
went to the drama to party and there was
literally like a guy tending bar
and a girl topless you know lying down
with her back up on the on the floating
mattress in the pool at night with the
lights on and cool Jazz playing and it
was like 30 to one girls to the to ratio
to men and I was like this makes much
more sense much much more pleasing yes
if a tree falls in a forest does it make
a sound yes it probably does but if 27
000 trees fall in a forest would you
rethink what you're using for toilet
paper I would hope so every day 27
000 trees are cut down just to make
conventional toilet paper that's almost
10 million trees a year just to make
something that you use once and then you
flush it down the toilet yeah that's
terrible but that is where real paper
comes in real makes a sustainable toilet
paper that contains no trees and instead
uses a hundred percent bamboo Bamboo is
an awesome sustainable option it's both
strong and soft and because it's a grass
bamboo can be continually harvested
without damaging the planet itself and
while the other conventional papers are
wrapped in plastic in the grocery aisle
real papers packaging is plastic free
compostable and offers free shipping on
all orders now if you're gonna use
something that is you know
in the bathroom area yes you may as well
use something that you feel a little
less guilty about when you just get rid
of it in one case don't a toilet it goes
dumb real paper is available in Easy
hassle-free subscriptions or for
one-time purchases on their website all
orders are conveniently delivered to
your door with free shipping and 100
recyclable plastic free packaging if you
head to realpaper.com onion and sign up
for their subscription using the code
onion at checkout you'll automatically
get 30 off your first order and free
shipping that's r e e l p a p e r.com
slash onion and enter the code onion to
get 30 off your first order plus free
shipping so let's start flushing our
forest and try reels tree free paper
real is paper for the planet
foreign
running a business your employees can
create all kinds of interesting
situations somebody isn't showing up
when they're supposed to you need to
talk to Mandy with Bambi get access to
your own dedicated HR manager starting
at just 99 a month they're available by
phone email and real-time chat so
onboarding and termination runs smoothly
team members reach Peak Performance and
your business stays compliant with
changing HR regulations and with Bambi's
HR autopilot you automate important HR
practices like certain policies training
and of course feedback it can be tricky
at times if you want to fire someone
right maybe you don't want to be in the
middle of that situation you need
someone from the outside taking care of
it that's why that could be Bambi right
there that's why you need Bambi HR
managers can cost 80 grand a year Bambi
starts at 99 per month schedule your
free conversation today to see how much
Andy can take off your plate go to
bambi.com right now and type in onion
under podcast when you sign up it will
really help the show spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e.com bambi.com type in onion
ugly bamboo and I want to send you
um
am I right in saying that you studied in
London well I was there for a split
second because of the draft I was
accepted at the Royal Academy but when
the Dr the draft wouldn't let me stay
there because uh it wasn't a draft
deferable uh University oh no so I I I I
I came back but here's the great happy
accident
the Royal Academy of dramatic art had a
huge Vision fissure uh uh between the
old school uh tutors and principal John
fernald and the sort of Peter Brooke new
modern touchy-feely approach and the Old
School faculty came to America and they
found this uh city outside of Detroit
that had a huge Arts uh a budget and
they had a a theater on the campus of
this major university beautiful theater
and in fact all of the English actors
lived at the Matilda Matilda Dodge as in
Dodge cars estate had the largest indoor
riding rink in the world and but
screening rooms with tile around the
fireplace with images of the guests
Charlie Chaplin you know and everyone in
it built into the tile and that's where
the that's where the Brits all lived you
know and then they performed in this
wonderful theater and I was asked to
become part of that company because I
had you know auditioned for Ron so I
finished my my router training there and
then at night you know every evening I'd
go over and I would be an understudy and
I would be on the scenery crew or the
property crew and uh it was just it it
just turned out to be even better than I
expected and where was that this was
just outside of Detroit what was it
called Meadowbrook theater yeah it's
still there it's a wonderful thing
you're a Michigan enthusiastic well I
worked at Summer Stock in the upper
peninsula and I went to Chicago a lot I
worked in Chicago and Atlanta and
regional theater all over there and we
worked with a lot of great actors from
Stratford Ontario which back then this
is the late 60s was probably the best
theater in North America right yeah
easily on a par with uh uh Ellis Rab's
American Repertory Theater and Lincoln
Center just Christopher Plummer people
like that we're working at Stratford
Ontario so a lot of those actors would
come down to our theater because we're
right across the border from Canada to
get in hours on their American Equity
card on their Union cards yeah I
remember when I used to go to Detroit
people would go over to Canada because
it had Stronger Beer oh yeah and you
could bring it back they were allowed to
have more more alcohol content yeah yeah
oh yeah we were always going to Windsor
Windsor that's right yeah yeah
um and that time that you spent in
London with Radha before you came back
do you know what what year that was I
believe well I was there for a minute it
was I think it was 68 and that because I
mean
1968 London is one of the real places
one of the actors uh that I uh worked
with in America we had several I mean
the entire faculty was English it was
from Rada right but and they had just
done chimes at midnight with our and
Wells and things like that but one of
the actors one of the student actors uh
my buddy Michael uh he had been he had
transferred uh to us from I think from
Rada in London and Michael were telling
me about you know stealing milk one day
and I think he got caught by Mary Ann
faithful
which I love that story stealing milk
bottles because he was a starving actor
in London and Mary Ann faithful busted
him opened the door you know in a
bathrobe
that in cleavage you know so then did
you just start touring around doing
plays I well I worked at the Meadowbrook
right uh I was brought into that company
which was great and I did a lot of shows
there but I also did regional theater uh
Repertory Theater in um uh the the most
difficult one was in in Cleveland and I
did revolving Repertory of Shakespeare
which because you know you do a solo one
night and then the next night you're
doing Taming of the Shrew but I also in
that a theater I landed uh the role of
Judas in God's spell and that was sort
of my first you know huge hit I had
groupies and uh and fans that saw the
show dozens of times and and you know to
to be in a play with a rock band playing
underneath you all the time again it's
that great cheap thrill of feeling like
a rock star yeah and I'm I don't sing
and I Just Dance a little but but it was
great being part of that you know part
of that experience wow yeah and I I had
times in when when I because I always
wanted to be an actor when I was a kid
but there would there were certainly
times where I thought well I'll give it
another go for another year and
hopefully at some point it will start to
you know work out for me but was there
was there a year where you thought okay
this is me now like I am a professional
actor this is what's happening like come
Cinco swim this is my job or were you
also thinking well I could also do this
if it doesn't work out well one of the
reasons I left home I never I didn't see
see my parents for years I was supposed
to be a lawyer back when I was a young
man you know being an artist a musician
an actor wasn't a big option a poet and
now a lot of young people gravitate
towards that but then parents were quite
strict they wanted you to be an engineer
or a doctor or a lawyer and I had been
recruited by Stanford University uh
because I was well-rounded in school not
that I was particularly a genius but I
was very well-rounded and I I had
skipped a grade and so they had
recruited me and that's a famous law
school and I I'd said no and and broke
my father's heart and so I had left home
but for me the two big moments where I
knew it was forever you get your union
card as a stage actor yeah you got my
union card as a film actor but my very
first movie I had single card credit
and that seeing the family name
unchanged single card credit uh made my
father it just patched up everything
between us you know and I was brought
back into the fold so to speak what
phone was that a film called Buster and
Billy 1973. and I was fourth billing I
think in that but I was unable to go to
the rap party and uh the screening party
after the screening in Hollywood and it
was at the the now defunct but then the
number one restaurant in Hollywood which
was chasins on Doheny and it was like I
mean the booths are like Jimmy Stewart
Clark Gable Gregory Peck that's who's
and my father knew about this place my
father and mother had actually eaten
there right you know before so my father
went to my opening screening party with
uh Jan Michael Vincent and it kind of
took my dad around and uh the the
actress in the film Pamela Sue Martin
and they kind of squired my father
around you know and he had the famous
chili you know and and everything thing
there and and he saw my the family name
all by itself and I had him in the palm
of my hand you're back inside yeah back
in the family there you go I love it and
how about because we're thinking about
moments in your career that you know
people obviously listening to this and
thinking about how did the the project
come about because that's a moment for a
lot of people when they're thinking
about your career where they say oh yeah
that that really breakout show that
Robert did I'd done a lot
when I did I when I did the in fact
almost exclusively filmed but that's the
project and we've all done this the
project where they learn your name yeah
they put your name finally you know to
your face they've seen you before and
they like you but you're that guy and
then I go to school with you but that's
where they finally put the name to my
face and that's a really important thing
uh as an actor it's also was an
international success for me and uh that
opened the doors for me to work abroad
which is something they never teach you
in drama school you know about about how
when you can work globally and that was
pretty early for me that would have been
82 I think uh but uh it was a weird
audition I had no clue what to do but
but the great Kenneth Johnson you know
Incredible Hulk and Bionic Man Bionic
Woman bionic dog you know but but Kenny
Kenny's just a great guy and I I said
Kenny had what I'm an alien and I've
been sent to the wrong City and I'm I
make Mal props i i i i misuse my
vocabulary you know I'm translating from
Alien into Arabic into into English I
said I I don't have a clue and he looked
at me and he just said well you're going
to have a little bit of a comedy relief
aspect to your role but he said two
words I said what he goes Gene Wilder
yeah so I just channeled Gene Wilder and
kind of tried to hide all the stuff I
was borrowing
from Gene you know a bit of a stutter
things like that uh and that innocence
yeah which works great that that Gene
Wilder innocence because you're you're
an alien's like a baby everything's new
to you yeah you know and that was such a
a key to unlock the door because I
didn't know what to do yeah you know and
that's that great advice we all get sure
that's funny isn't it because when you
watch something like that you just you
just think the the actor is totally
assured if they're good at their their
job so you don't you never think of the
that there might be you weren't sure
what you were going to do like when I
think of that character you just think
wow that guy nailed that straight away
because it was a standout character of
the show kind of thing well I was I was
getting I think the most fan mail at one
time and I visited a friend on another
show called Hotel on the Warner Brothers
lounge and there's that that thing with
the uh uh little cubby holes that are
behind a hotel desk on the on the set
where you know the keys are put and if
you get a a telegram they would put the
telegram in there yeah and uh I I went
over to visit my friend he goes Robert
come here look and the cubby holes were
full of letters
to look like telegrams and they were my
fan mail they never gave me my fan mail
that came to the lot these stuff that
came to my home I got her to my agent
but they were just using it as this
price that's when I had an inkling you
know right maybe I better renegotiate
you yeah so I had an inkling that that
uh the character had kind of taken off
yeah
um that's my wife's favorite of uh your
work she loves that she ABS but she was
sitting to me this morning honestly she
says but how how is that the same guy
that did Freddie and did that chalk and
cheese yeah yes what does John Lovett
say acting yeah yeah and actually you
guys know this and we we don't always
admit this but extremes are easier to do
and we all know that's that middle work
yeah right closest to the soul that's
the hard stuff yeah you know where you
really have to throw your tricks away
your bag of tricks away yeah and uh and
and just really kind of hone in on on
inner truth and listening yeah that's
hard stuff because you really feel naked
you know you know if I if you give me
give me a cane and a mustache yeah
today's episode is sponsored by true
classic guys let's talk about t-shirts
finding that perfect fitting shirt can
be terrible you know what the things
either it's too tight gives you a big
neck or it's just brilliant it's just
big boxes yeah you look silly yeah so
luckily true classic wants to make every
man look good and feel good take a fit
in the chest sleeves made to make your
arms put room in the Torso it keep
things cozy I'm telling you all these
styles are super soft great price but
what you're getting so guys no excuses
get rid of those horrible t-shirts been
hanging around for years get an upgrade
and we've got an exclusive deal for our
listeners we want to hook you up with
some true classic for our limited team
only get 25 off with the code onion at
trueclassic.com almost all men's
t-shirts are designed to look good on a
certain body type things skinny models
with six packs but most of us aren't
packing anything like that we've just
got a few beers I'm like really you know
and there's nothing wrong with that my
dude it's simple you are wearing the
wrong clothes true classic tees taper
off towards the bottom but they fit
tighter around the chest and shoulders
you can throw on that true classic your
confidence knowing you've got your bases
covered two classics will make your best
by accentuating the places the eyes go
first
whether you have amps or flaps their
clothes look great on all body types
skinny dudes big dudes like billionaire
buff dudes like me my huge dudes true
Classics get comfortable get going and
upgrade your wardrobe with tour classy
get 25 off at trueclassic.com with the
code onion free shipping including on
purchases over a hundred dollars a
hundred percent risk-free guarantee with
a 30 day return policy true classic when
you look good you feel good
okay
well speaking of fan mail you are just
just a little bit older than his Robert
but do you remember the first time that
you went to a convention and how it's
changed over the years because even for
me in the 15 20 years that I've been
doing it it's become a completely
different beast but you must have seen
crazy changes well actually I think I
probably started close to the same time
you guys did I didn't really get into it
until after Freddie versus Jason that's
not to say that I hadn't done
some conventions before that but mostly
film festivals yeah that's what I enjoy
doing and Q a is there yeah and you sign
a little bit at film festivals as well
um but Freddie versus Jason was so huge
coming at the end of the accumulated
franchise that it really made the
conventions you know a kind of bump for
me but I do remember going to Comic-Con
very early probably for VM yeah and
because there was a comic book for V and
Comic-Con was still comic books yeah at
that time so I do remember that that
brief moment of time you know that that
when that shift happened uh and then all
of a sudden one day you go to a con and
there's Nicole Kidman you know yeah yeah
it's just changed yeah it's changed and
then for for people I think it is a bit
of that Halloween thing you get to dress
up you get yeah you know it's definitely
changed from the comic book but I have
to ask though but I kind of
for my wife even though we as you say
the the extremes are sort of easier and
stuff but how
like how close was Freddie to the and
time wise I mean and getting cast and
how the person that cast how did they
think oh Willy from from V that's who we
won well it was very close in fact they
overlapped uh the mini series was 10
hours and then the series of the and
between the Hiatus between I think the
second miniseries and the television
series was when I did I had this little
island of time a Hiatus and I was able
to fit Nightmare on Elm Street in but
I was established in in Hollywood
already yeah uh I'd been working for 10
years and almost exclusively filmed I'd
already been Typecast as a southerner
yeah and I'd been Typecast as a sidekick
and a best friend for many years but
what I knew growing up in Hollywood and
knowing a bit of the history of film is
that Sidekicks were not aging well right
used to be that John Wayne and Jimmy
Stewart they had older friends mentors
yeah or older Sidekicks Like Walter
Brennan uh uh the older character actors
would play their buddies and that was
the sort of way the Trope that was the
way it was structured but for my
generation the sidekicks were getting
younger and younger and younger and I
was starting to age out of those you
know the kind of best friend psychic
which is an element of Hollywood that's
necessary and needed and it's a great
thing if that's what you're typed as but
I saw that as not as sort of having an
end to it you know a dead end to it and
I started doing bad guys a little bit
because I'd been typed as a southerner
and a lot of a lot of a lot of villains
and Heavies were written Southern so I
did that a little bit and then I kind of
was playing nerds for a little bit uh
because I've always worn glasses off and
on and I guess you know the way I looked
um but you know I the V was I told you
about the V audition you know the Gene
Wilder uh help and Nightmare
it's a woman that cast me in Nightmare
Annette Benson she
had auditioned me for every role
in a National Lampoon project
literally and I canceled myself out I
don't know if that's ever happened to
you guys where they they like you the
casting person likes you the director
likes you but they don't know what which
part to use you for so you go up for two
or three roles in the same project and
you kind of cancel yourself with your
magnificent versatility no but you know
that can happen yeah and it was a very
great lesson to learn because I I never
did that again I never I used to say
after three callbacks no they've seen
all they've seen anything I can do yeah
they either want me or they don't I'm
not going back again and uh
so she felt bad about that that I didn't
I wound up with nothing in that film and
I I wanted it so bad because I love
National Lampoon and SNL Off-Broadway
and Belushi and Bill Murray and all of
that and uh
and I'd like some of I'd like Animal
House and the other projects and this
movie flopped but at that time I wanted
it so desperately but I think she felt
bad and she was really in my corner with
Wes Craven you know she may have been
whispering in in his ear and I'll tell
you something and this is really honest
and this is with hindsight I have a
narrow face and I have broad shoulders
and you can put that crap on me you can
you know put that colostomy bag
medical adhesive all over me and stick
Prosthetics on me and my head shape and
size is still in ratio with my torso and
if you've noticed sometimes you'll see
an effects makeup and the head looks too
big yeah yeah but with me it didn't they
were terrified about the makeup uh the
head of new line Cinema in Wes Craven
and I think that they were they were so
worried that that seeing that I had a
thin face
that I could take the application and it
would work I think that that may have
been it may have been that simple
um now Wes says I was the only guy that
understood his pitch of the theme and
what the movie was about and I love that
compliment from from Wes but I don't
know if he was just giving lip service
or if he really meant that it could have
been as simple as as me having a thin
face I know they wanted a big stunt man
originally uh and they but I you know I
went in I greased my hair back with uh
motor oil from under the hood of my
Roadster and I'd put cigarette Ash under
my eyes I love it you know with a little
bit of saliva yeah to sink my eyes I
love it because I was all blonde and bro
I was Surfer blonde and brown and so my
hair is fine so you could sort of see my
skull through my hair and then I sunk my
eyes so I looked a little less tan and
healthy and I played the old staring
game
remember as kids don't blink I did the
don't blink with Wes kept my mouth shut
you know I love to talk Billy
um big mouth shut and just stared back
and listened to Wes and I think that
might have been the trick really you
know well the makeup in all of those
films is extraordinary but I mean even
if you're talking about the original now
the makeup in that original film is so
good and still stands up to this day
like it is truly terrifying makeup on
Friday you know I used to love to take
credit for wearing the makeup so many
times but then I met I met one of your
lot one of your lonsmen uh and I'm
forgetting his name now begins with an S
the general orc and maybe
um
Milton Keynes
at the little Pub in the little hotel
we're all staying at an absolutely guys
and we got drunk and he told me
how long his makeup took as the general
orc and apparently if he had to be used
by nine in the morning he was in the
makeup chair at like 2 A.M yeah for
makeup yeah so I've stopped bragging
right I remember I was rapping at one
point and Salah was in the makeup chair
and we were like wait what you doing
we're rapping you're putting your makeup
on now he said we'll put in my makeup on
now for tomorrow morning so we were
going to bed he was going through the
night yeah but here's the thing Robert
myself and Dom here right and the other
two Hobbits we're in the Guinness book
of records for spending the most time in
a makeup chair on a project oh yeah
because it was forever because you know
other families
because Salome have been in there for 15
hours yeah we did three hours every day
every day yeah and that was how long did
the how long did Freddie take Freddy's
three and a half a fat three significant
and then sometimes lenses right and and
a lot of times teeth if they're shooting
me close yeah if you're not shooting me
close to no teeth uh but again uh my my
Stephen King makeup for The Mangler took
longer because there's hair involved
yeah and my my Phantom of the Opera
makeup took longer because it was hair
and it was makeup
of me
over half of my face disintegrated so
it's it was a mold of Robert England
right
over Robert England with half of Robert
England done destroyed you know like the
mask on Broadway of course yeah so that
was boy that was four and a half five
hours and how do you feel I take it for
those ones you had to have a a head mold
done how do you feel about getting those
done you guys hate him as much as I do I
it's the it's the one of the major times
in my life where I just think you have
to meditate there's no way out of this
you're just breathing I think it's
breathing yeah really slow your
breathing down yeah but that moment
where it gets really hot tight they tell
you it's gonna do that it's hot and
tight yeah for people that should change
and you don't believe it and then you
feel it and you kind of go well they did
tell me this was going to happen yeah
but now it's tightening yeah you've got
the straws in your nose
that's for anyone who doesn't know this
on your face yeah yeah making a head uh
a cast which means they they cover your
whole face with I I don't even know what
it is but I mean it's like well it's
like a silicone
it's not just your makeup it's the mold
yeah yeah and it may be you know you're
there for an hour and you start to think
there's only those two little holes that
I'm breathing out of and you if you
start thinking about that too much and
the last one I did which wasn't very
long ago six months ago it was a heavy
one and when you went you take it off it
was getting stuck it was a whole head
one and I thought the two holes from my
nose have now moved I'm like where am I
breathing from though I was really
starting it does get I think you could I
mean I
I have actually
I think it's claustrophobia yeah which
kicks in there because you do and you
want to and you have to just say Keep
Your Hands yeah yeah you know but
there's that instinct just yeah you rip
at it yeah yeah they said the last one I
did was in Borneo a couple years ago and
great process but before it began the
guy said anything comes up and you need
to get out just put your hand up and
we'll get you out immediately and I was
like okay and there was probably two or
three occasions where I thought you have
to [ __ ] really yeah because the
natural emotion human instinct is like I
gotta get out of this I can't breathe
slow breathe slow count to four inhale
exhale but it's also you hear that saw
yeah yeah
it's like where's Penn and Teller you
know it's like what's going on here yeah
that's not the most Pleasant thing and
the sound that you hear
you know in the mold yeah and under
under the the Frozen foam and latex you
that sound it's it's muffled yeah so
strange yeah and you're hearing people
go wrong no problem
and then you start to think of Freddy
Krueger yeah he may be in here maybe
somewhere that's just I mean we're just
such manly men that we can do that
because there's stories about famous
actors yeah you can't do that yeah or
that freaked out oh well lived on our
film lovely beautiful amazing live Tyler
really really struggled with her face
mask you're not allowed to see who
struggles
person a person did all this basically
affects people if they tell you who can
do it they all say but never see her
yeah
and I also think it was sort of public
knowledge but on the on the sting
Frankenstein with Jennifer Beal I think
the actor and I can't remember his name
one of my favorite directors though
Frank Rodham but apparently he just had
horrible horrible uh allergic relax
actions to the uh to the glues ah yeah
yeah and they had to like reshoot
everything and it sent the budget
that was the same with uh John Rhys
Davis on uh Lord of the Rings when he
put on his Prosthetics he had to be off
for two weeks because his eyes would all
I just couldn't do it so as his um stunt
man had to be on set a lot you know with
his back to camera and things Robert
I'll tell you my nightmare Elm Street
story because it's it's it's got quite a
lot of trauma associated with it
there at my school say Anne's in
Manchester
with you know my social group and the
year that I was in there were certain
films that you had to see to get a
little stamp of approval that you could
handle it so The Exorcist approval yes
The Exorcist was big Friday the 13th
Halloween
I'd seen Halloween Friday the 13th had
not seen The Exodus because I was warned
by people it is genuinely scary and at
that point the other one the massive
standout one was Nightmare Elm Street so
I thought okay if it's if it's around
about the same place as Friday the 13th
and Halloween I can handle it went out
to my cousins it was 13. way too young
watched it get them when they're young
my God Robert I was terrified terrified
and it was made even worse by the fact
that in my local area there was a kid
called Ian who wanted to be called
Freddy because he had a Freddy Krueger
jumper the red and black stripe thing
made his own glove wore the trousers had
the hat so at night time if I was going
for my mum and dad to get bread or milk
or eggs or something he'd be on the side
of the street like
I had not I had nightmares about him had
nightmares about Nightmare on street I
remember the night that I'd watched it
with my cousins and my brother we went
home that night never happened to me
ever since I was in bed and I was like
whimpering awake and my brother we
shared a bunk bed we was like it's okay
Dom it's okay he knew that I was scared
I wasn't even asleep at this point I was
just scared that it was dark and then
years later when I was in my kind of
mid-20s I had a nightmare that uh my
brother had his hand cut off I read
Kruger and it was incredibly
traumatizing so you did an amazing job
well Dom you you got even with with me
with your uh Pratt election for reptiles
nothing for you you're not into snakes
yeah that's sort of uh I I was a child
and walked into a children's matinee uh
in the summer I think it was a cowboy
movie with Anthony Quinn again Anthony
Quinn I must have been an Anthony Quinn
fan I think it was the man from Del Rio
you know the gunfighter who's they're
trying to Dethrone him you know the old
gunfighter and it wasn't playing
they had turned on the evening
's fair and it was Norman mailers the
naked and the dead and it's a war movie
so I'm okay I think oh World War II I
like World War II movies and I'm sitting
there and at some point in the tropics
pursuing the Japanese the American
soldiers in the South Pacific one of
them is bit by a lime green translucent
snake and he Foams at the mouth and and
and he Foams out of the nose and out of
the ears you know and it's this horrible
death and his buddy you know hacks the
snake in pieces and holds
traumatized for the rest of the year I
looked under my bed and in my drawers
for for translucent greens tropical
snakes it's crazy it affected me for
years yeah it's bizarre the moment that
resonated for me I think more than
anything else in that first movie which
I still believe is the most terrifying
out of all the nightmare Elm Streets is
the moment where Freddy's chasing Tina
down that Alleyway and she says oh God
and Freddie says no this is God is God
and I was like huh
that sequence with uh the actress Amanda
Wiss who played Dina on the revolving we
had a revolving room that's how they got
her on the ceiling because she was
really you know right side up then and
they just stressed everything and glued
everything down and nailed everything
down but that still holds up that's a
horrific wonderful sea type you know and
that's just the old Fred Astaire
revolving room right you know uh trick I
think we borrowed it at that time when
for Johnny Depp's it's the same room as
Johnny Depp had where all the blood
rushes out of the bed yeah and that's
just gravity it's just it's obviously
the bed is on the ceiling that's in it
the blood's just dripping you know
straight down and so you have gravity's
help to make it look like it's gushing
but we got that idea from the elevator
bleeding in uh
yeah because that's how Kubrick did that
right yeah Johnny Depp's first ever uh
professional gig right do you do you
have any recollection of of him working
with him well I know you guys like music
I think Johnny was thought of himself
then as a musician yeah he was in a band
in Miami and uh I think it was
rockabilly I'm not sure because his
style in real life then was very Rocky
he did the best hair the best hair
leather jacket the best hair ever and
and those great shirts you know those
great you know uh and just I mean I
couldn't you know really good hair but I
remember Johnny he said he that he was
March going on April and the Christmas
tree was still up in his apartment
somewhere in Miami he said he knew it
was time to leave come out last year but
he was just this polite kid you know yes
sir no sir Mr England so I said stop it
you're making me sound like I'm your
teacher here or something but I just
remember him being very very polite you
know and the a story I heard was that
Wes's daughter Wes Craven's daughter saw
Johnny in the waiting room for his
audition and before she even heard him
read her actor and she just walked in
and said Dad hire him or I'll never
speak to you again and I had my I
brought my girlfriend uh over because I
was doing makeup tests and wardrobe
tests and uh I remember and she was at
Yale then uh uh Yale drama school and
her class was just full of people we all
know now and she had a great eye for
talent uh and I remember her saying just
seeing him and she said he's going to be
a star really she just glanced at it
yeah he's got that he kind of jumps off
the screen doesn't he
um and my memory of that movie it seemed
to be like the movies that you you
listed on you know Friday the 13th and
all that but nightmares seemed to become
bigger than all of them yeah I think
it's because it's about adolescence it's
about the loss of Innocence we had a
strong girl heroin yeah the Survivor
girl the final girl yeah but the the
idea
that you could be haunted from a dream
to death yeah that's Universal so we
were an international hit immediately
out of the gate everybody has the same
you know people in Antarctica people in
in the uh Aleutian Islands and in Africa
and everywhere
they have we all have common dreams in
the falling dream the drowning dream the
suffocating dream of flying dream we all
have those dreams it's part of the DNA
of humanity yeah and the idea that
somebody could get into the privacy of
your own subconscious and turn that
against yourself I think it's just a
great gimmick yeah and those young
people saying just don't sleep that was
the thing wasn't it because once you saw
it and it was the first it was the first
movie I I ever saw that was an 18
and I remember it like it was yesterday
as well and I remember being on the bus
going home in Glasgow with friends and
just thinking I will never sleep yeah it
was so as you see it I think because it
was adolescence we were adolescent you
identify just remember the newspapers
just don't sleep don't sleep and you're
like okay I wouldn't I would yeah well
you're so vulnerable when you sleep it
also became a great date movie because
yeah guys realize that women love that
movie because they followed the girl's
Journey the guys were watching Freddie
in the special effects and and the
scares but the women were identifying
with her journey will she survive yeah
you know and every in every
episode of the franchise there's a girl
that defeats Freddie or survives Freddy
and and she's you know our our final
girl is not final she's a Survivor girl
and without going into a great you know
academic feminist dialogue here that was
we we did have strong women in each of
our movies and I think that that brought
in a lot of the original uh sort of
horror fan girls to the audience uh back
then so I I think that that's something
I'm kind of proud of uh not I didn't
write it I didn't create it it's
unintentional on my part but it's still
something that happened for sure as a
part of the phenomenon of that franchise
and were you were you always a fan of
the genre did you were you interested in
horror growing up yeah and you know this
is something that I suppress because I
became that guy in the corduroy jacket
in the turtleneck with the patches on
his sleeves that was never going back to
Hollywood never going to do television I
was only going to do the classics you
know and I was full of myself for a
while you know in the avant-garde and
off Off-Broadway and and uh political
theater and uh uh I loved grotowski and
everything I was obsessed with that
Peter Brooke uh empty space but
I had suppressed the fact that as a
child
I would mow Lawns and use my prophets
and my allowance and me and my mates
would go down on Saturday we talked some
mother into driving us to the local
movie theater and we would do the double
matinee the double Bill matinee and we
love the hammer horror which was all
imported for us and then our own
American Horror but I do remember yeah
loving it and I had a Godfather
who was a big book distributor for uh
Simon and Schuster the Publishing
Company probably handled most of their
stuff west of the Mississippi and he had
a big wonderful ranch house again
literally walking distance from here and
uh with a kidney-shaped pool and one of
the bedrooms was all of the coffee table
books that Simon and Schuster
distributed and one of them was called
the movies and it had a red cover on it
but I remember looking through the
horror section there was a great two two
page spread of Karlov and the little
girl at the lake and there was a great
spread from Dracula's daughters and if
you looked really close you could almost
see the daughter's nipples you know
Dracula's daughters in their sexy
transparent gowns you know and that that
set off some kind of a buzzer in my
pre-adolescent brain but then there was
a two-page spread of one one inch by one
inch images of all of the makeups that
Lon Chaney had worn and I was obsessed
with it in fact one of them was a
Placentia from an egg and he put it over
his eyeball
hard-boiled the egg to make his eye look
milky and blind so like the first
Contact Lens right yeah yeah but anyway
I'm wondering
was that summer that I was obsessed with
that book and I ditched my mom and dad
and my godparents every time I went over
there to swim in the pool and to look at
that book
I wondering if that was the little voice
in me when I was on that Wes Craven
interview so many years later you know
that I always wanted to mess with the
with the makeup you know that I was
fascinated with it and I remember what
you just said earlier in the interview
Billy about and drama school you have to
learn makeup yeah and and as a
professional actor you do your own
makeup on the stage you guys know that
and it's a skill and you know there's
always some old guy in the cast that's
better at it than you you know and he
has that great old makeup kit you know
with an old tackle box or something yeah
things you've never seen before that you
wish you had in yours because you want
to be cool like that but I was
fascinated with that part of being a
stage actor you know uh it's a weird
contrast to you know going to the
parties with all the best girls which
Dominic and I liked but also and but
also like your male you didn't tell your
male friends that you had a makeup kit
you know that was it would have been you
so you had to keep those lives separate
but I remember sitting with Old English
actors who had a ball and they would
wrap it in a tin foil and they would
take the tin foil off and hold it and it
looked kind of roughly like a globe of
the world you know all these different
colors and that's all they would use and
they would sink their temples and and
change their labial fold you know and
give themselves a cleft or five o'clock
shadow or highlight their eyes with all
the that's all they use these guys from
London's West End that do all these
tricks and as a I was just fascinated
with that kind of Backstage lore yeah
and and and art and you brought that
skills my uh my makeup box was my
favorite thing oh yeah when it came to
um the technical rehearsal and the dress
rehearsal and I get my box out and your
little towels
I mean I loved all that stuff
at an old coffee cup with my brushes and
my pencils in it but I've always loved
that about you Robert there's a kind of
there's a Lust For Life on all that
stuff and and whether it's you know the
history of English theater or or if it's
um or even food when we went to
Argentina and we're having food and wine
and going to museums you've got a real
Lust For Life that is uh well what else
what else is there to do yeah you know
what I mean but I love that
and that's what I mean about kind of
Hollywood and movies it feels like you
love that do you love the history I
think you know I was so aligned with the
theater and when I
came back to Hollywood and I'm from
Southern California and I know my way
around and I I know where the best
apartments are hidden up in the hills
and things so it's easier for me than a
lot of actors here but my then
girlfriend who would go on to write Lost
Boys uh my title her movie uh but in
fact two of my roommates wrote that
movie James jeremias and and my
girlfriend did you did you come up with
that the title well because the original
fake out the original fake out of the
original draft
when you're above the town
going through the clouds the cameras
going through the clouds the original
fake out is a Peter Pan myth to fake you
out when it's revealed that they're not
that they're actually vampires you see
and uh uh but when I moved into
Hollywood
my then girlfriend we had a thing up by
the phone
and it was all the Revival houses like
the like the New Beverly Cinema and
there was one in Venice and there was
one in Santa Monica and every night
there was a pristine print double bill
of film Noir or two great classic horror
movies by Val Newton I walked with a
zombie or Double Indemnity or some great
John Ford Western a perfect print and
every night you could go for a dollar or
a dollar 25 you could go see some so I
sort of learned relearned the history of
Hollywood and of Classic Cinema because
I sort of had to clean my brain and
cleanse myself from all of my uh
affectation and attitude coming from the
theater you know and I wanted to love
film and watch it so that's sort of why
that was those couple of years there is
71 72 73. that's sort of when I was
doing a lot of that and that sort of
became my my knowledge of the history of
Hollywood because they were these people
that I was with were going to see movies
at the Museum and going to see the film
festival film X at the old ramen's
Chinese and stuff and I'm dragging me
along and I was just introduced to this
entire history of Hollywood in the
Silver Screen I knew porn films because
I was that I was that guy
yes I was going to see Antonio films
right right and uh things like that but
so I knew I was already kind of caught
up on the foreign films but uh it just
made me respect and love American
American movie making well speaking of
American movie man king could you just
talk to us a little bit about Wes Craven
because obviously a luminary
filmmaker who you know changed the genre
of films and you you worked with him for
what was it 20 years off and on oh I did
a television series with Wes as well a
nightmare Cafe no you know I think the
gift Wes had
he was able to keep the 14 year old boy
alive in him you know he used to do kind
of adolescent puns a lot any brilliant
guy brilliant guy but
I think he was stunted a bit as a child
I think his parents were very
conservative and Wes was uh only allowed
to see Disney films and even then on a
limited basis so he was playing catch-up
a bit with what had occurred in the
American culture during his childhood uh
the horror movies art movies rock and
roll uh things like that he was sort of
playing catch-up with it and he loved
all of that you know he was interested
in all of it uh he wasn't just a horror
director that's sort of what befell him
because of his early success but I
remember sitting in a New Wave Bar
remember the new wave you guys
yeah yeah so I was sitting in this new
wave bar I had a little crush on the
bartender I'd go in there and kill time
before I'd call my agent at the end of
the day after auditions and meetings and
she was a cutie pie you know she had
real kind of Sinead O'Connor looking uh
with a little leather jacket on you know
and at either end of the bar were these
giant monitors with TVs stuck in them
and on one end they would play a
continuous loop of scenes from a racer
head the David Lynch yeah yeah and on
the other one they would play continuous
Loops of The Hills Have Eyes and Last
House on the Left in black and white wow
they were they were like black and white
videos or something racer head is
so I Associated Wes with David Lynch as
a an artist of the dark dark arts you
know uh with a dark Viewpoint yeah and
uh and that's one reason I wanted to
audition for him
um but Wes was just I mean every time I
visited he had Steve McQueen's old
bachelor pad at the top of Nichols
Canyon you know overlooking this city
all the way to the ocean and uh every
time I went over there and it wasn't a
lot but there was always some great
coffee table book he was interested in
something you know tattoos or or masks
or something and there was always some
great new music he was listening to and
and stuff like that he was just open to
everything I don't know if you've seen
his uh evil Voodoo movie The Serpent and
the rainbow oh no no with Bill Pullman
Bill Pullman yeah but that it you know
he's that's one of his terrific film on
location Haiti wow there's a there's a
story in and of itself but yeah Wes is
just really was a remarkable guy and I
miss him every day and you know none of
us knew we I thought he broke his leg
and you know when you get older it takes
long to rehab and heal and I thought he
was just walking a dog on the Beach on
Cape Cod you know with his new beautiful
wife and and and rehabbing you know and
just sort of wanted to get better before
he saw us all again I knew he had some
TV projects and I was hoping to be
invited on one or two yeah and and and
then he passed and I was in London with
Amanda Wiss who played Tina in the
original and we just it just took the
wind out of our sails you know we walked
straight into a pub and yeah yeah and
we're there for hours we just we
couldn't believe it because no one knew
that he had anything wrong with him we
just thought it would you know oh you
know the worst it could be is a knee
replacement hip replacement you know
um and did he tell you where the origins
of that original Nightmare on Elm Street
story came from where did he think that
up I think Freddy Krueger was a bully oh
yeah and and that's a real name I think
wow and or Freddy's a real name or
Kruger's the real name or perhaps both
of them but he liked Krueger because it
was Germanic and it was that uh uh
Grimm's Fairy Tale aspect that dark
fairy tale cautionary tale thing that he
liked and that's sort of the Freddy
element now there was an experience he
had with his brother left alone in the
home mom and dad were out I don't know
they went to church or something but
wasn't his brother were left alone alone
and they were upstairs in a bedroom
I think it had Venetian blinds
and they were going to bed and they
closed the blinds and when Wes looked
out he saw this what we used to call a
hobo I don't know what the politically
correct thing is now for you know how
unhoused a bum who had soot on his face
and a fedora I don't know if he had a
red and green stripe sweater on he may
have just had an Overcoat on or
something but he was Simon he looked up
and caught Wes's eye and I think Wes
turned off the light yeah and peaked at
him through the Venetian blinds and then
got back in bed with his brother and
told his brother about it and apparently
a few minutes later the brother got up
to check
and the guy was still there now they
crept downstairs
and they went and they looked through
the the eye hole the keyhole the eye
hole in the door and uh the guy was now
standing in the front walkway looking at
their front door
nothing else to happen but those things
happen yeah and that was a kind of a
source story I think yeah wow Billy and
Dom eat the world
talking about formative stories uh as
you know Robert me and Dom like to eat
the world on our podcast and you said
that maybe you have a story from your
childhood that involves some food well
I've been warned and I I narrowed it
down to two my pizza in Naples or my ice
cream sandwich childhood traumas well we
can't do pizza in Naples I'm gonna do
I'm going to do the Ice Cream Sandwich
trauma so I'm in kindergarten looking
forward to this in the valley Johnny
there you go buddy oh thank you look at
this I'm fine hold on Robert
I think I know a little bit of this
story so could you give me a plate for a
second oh what are you gonna do I think
that I don't think at this point the
delicious part of it save some for me no
I don't I don't know this story go on so
my Elementary School in Encino
California
where I live down the street from Clark
Gable uh
was originally a dairy it was called
Rhoda Street like Rhoda the girl from
Bad Seed right Rhoda Street Elementary
School which wrote a spelled backwards
is Ador and adore was this very very
popular very huge dairy in Southern
California and in fact they were the
people that delivered your milk and your
eggs and your butter yeah at the door
the Milkman so they were doing a
marketing research right on children's
taste buds at my elementary school yeah
and using my kindergarten class and the
night before I'd been given a permission
slip brought it in you know we're
supposed to have your parents sign it
yeah to be part of this experiment this
this merchandising uh uh test and I was
afraid because I told that we were told
by the teacher you're going to get to
eat an ice cream sandwich now at the age
of five all I could think of was that
terrible white bread that everybody ate
back in the 1950s with a scoop of
vanilla ice cream on it and that just
sounded disgusting to me yeah so it does
so yeah I threw the permission slip away
I didn't tell my parents I show up the
next day and in my classroom are these
wonderful uniform people dressed like
Milkmen and everybody is handed oh God I
still don't have one all these years
later I was handed this ice cream
sandwich which was this wonderful
chocolate like graham crackers or with
this melty vanilla french vanilla bean
ice cream in between it and all of my
classmates are eating it and it's
melting and they're licking their lips
and they've been given these little
personalized napkins and they're
devouring it and I'm stuck with my
mother's lunch that she prepared for me
and all that's left after my peanut
butter and jelly sandwich are my carrot
sticks
and my celery well that's what we've got
now that's that's absolutely that's what
I'm left with now
I can not give you an ice cream sandwich
come on in honor of that story we've got
raw carrots raw celery and an ice cream
sandwich
so this was them trying to work out if
kids were gonna leave if kids were gonna
like it and then after that they got
another cooler and they walked this
other cooler in
with a frost coming off of it and they
opened it up and then they gave us not
me but everybody else every other every
other classmate of mine the spamoni the
spamoni Neapolitan ice cream sandwich
modeled after the Italian ice cream
Spumoni and it was strawberry French
vanilla and chocolate oh yeah together
I think the ice cream when it's mixed
like that is called spamona do you know
I've I've never had an ice cream
sandwich
I have never known my years when I was
when I was growing up I grew up in the
schemes in Glasgow they had this idea
there was too many people staying in uh
the the town of Glasgow so they made
these schemes and the outskirts the
council and and safety people go and
live out there but they didn't build any
stores or that happened in California
too they did the same thing urban sprawl
so urban sprawl so get out there but
then all these people were stuck with no
stores nothing to do all the kids would
become Hooligans because there was
nothing for them to do and an ice cream
van would come round and you could get
ice cream and the woman's name was Kelly
is that like the great Bill Forsyth film
exactly with the ice cream ice cream
Mafia
um comfort and joy comfort and shot God
what a great film with the wonderful
wonderful broken that wonderful life
yeah
Claire Grogan from A Gregory's girls in
it Gregory's girl that's right oh
I loved it that the ice cream Mafia ice
cream God was a real thing I finished my
ice cream sandwich so that was a real
thing Robert they're good aren't they
they're fantastic I absolutely love it
and I I was deprived the only kid wow in
kindergarten yeah you made a bad
decision well but I mean what are What A
Life Lesson you know get things signed
get your paperwork done get your
paperwork done but also also how we
imagine stuff and it's nothing like we
imagine it and think of all of the great
vegetables and fruits and things we were
children that we didn't want to have
because we didn't like the way they
looked or you know like like years ago
when people used to mock make fun of
anybody that had sushi and or or things
like that and now you know now we I mean
we love great Indian food and we love
Japanese food and we can't get enough of
Thai food and things like that yeah
that's true but you know we were all
finicky you know and Afraid like I was
like little Robbie England no one eat
white bread and ice cream we own the
Friendship onion we like to score the
food we give it scores out of ten is it
turn yeah thank you Dom
that that story was exhausting
so it's out of 10 and we have to um we
score it first off on taste or flavor
then we score on Aesthetics how it looks
and then we score it on
how useful is it
yeah I know Robert that's Billy's
category he came up with that one useful
food like William Boyd if it's in your
house yeah and people come round and you
know you're looking and maybe you're
getting a flower you've got eggs you've
got some orange juice you've got is
there anything you can make can you do
it how useful but anyway let's come back
to that flavor
but wait are we just to jump in for a
second are we just scoring the Ice Cream
Sandwich are we scoring the carrots and
celery just the ice cream okay copy that
because I'm enjoying the couch and
celery Robert flavor out of ten and you
can do a decimal point first you want to
go first as an example I liked it I
would like a little bit more punch to my
to my ice cream maybe a natural bit of
madagascan vanilla bean in there but I'm
gonna give it a solid
6.9
I'll like it back in Scotland we have
something like it called a nugget
which is a wafer on one side and then
it's like a cream-filled thing there
which I think is more interesting than
just the chocolate there but I liked it
a lot I'm gonna give it a 8.5 oh you did
like it I did you did like it well I am
conflicted because I have
the Marcel proust memory of course the
memory of
food before it was processed heavily
because as a child growing up
here every corner was a fresh produce
stand run by a Latino family who had
literally
a field of those vegetables
and the Bad Boys
in in high school that I went to school
with with a cigarette behind the ear
would eat a real basket not a plastic
basket but a real little basket full of
Sherry tomatoes and flip them and catch
them in their mouth like a peanut after
they salted it with a little camper salt
shaker so I remember when food and and
my memory of ice cream then and of ice
cream sandwiches was they were pure the
ice cream was better than this and that
the chocolate on it was more like a
graham cracker a chocolate graham
cracker but this did fulfill me and this
did taste good and it's you know for the
audience right now we're in the middle
of a heat wave here yeah and on a hot
day oh this ice cream so I'm going to
give it an eight okay
I would agree with you on the wafer side
as yeah there's something kind of fake
about that the Wafers are much more
processed and synthetic than they used
to be how does it look the Aesthetics of
it done well when it was in the little
cellophane wrapper before it started to
get squished and you know the little
square shape the platform
quite like that brown and white the
compliment
I'm going to give it an 8.5 well that's
quite high as well Tom yeah know that
Robert said that there is something
slightly fake about I'd like the white
not to be as white I want it to be more
vanilla a little vanilla bean well yes
you want the Neapolitan yeah oh yeah the
spamoni so I'm going to see it as a good
look but it's not amazing so I can only
give that a seven
well I think the packaging
is a little too reminiscent
I know this is this is one of Billy's
pet peeves but it's a little reminiscent
of airplane food
yeah and that's why I'm gonna give it uh
I'll give it a six and a half yeah six
point five yeah on the packaging okay
really and it also the way it's packaged
you can't really tell how long it's been
around oh yeah yeah you know the uh do
the the eat before date or they eat by
date and how how would you open that
without crushing it because the whole
yeah plastic no yeah okay usefulness how
useful is an ice cream sandwich is it
portable how long does it stay
not melty not long not long so I mean
you once it's out the freezer you've got
to be fast haven't you you could put it
into a
you could put it into a food processor
with some fruit you can make a smoothie
of some sort out of it I'd make an egg
because chocolate vanilla a couple of
strawberries in there a banana I've had
an ice cream sandwich birthday cake I
have had one and how was that it was
good it was a long time ago but I
remember someone said as a kid their
favorite thing was a nice Ice Cream
Sandwich so they got an ice cream
sandwich birthday cake and it was good
apart from that you're not really yeah I
mean you know very versatile is it so
I'm going to say it's not that useful
really I can only give it a four
because it's not you couldn't make a
soup from it no you couldn't it's a
three from me yeah yeah I don't know it
is kind of a useless food it is yeah I
mean it's like it's immediate you have
to take it out and eat it I'm just
trying to think if there's I mean I'm
trying to think I wonder what it would
be like
in a dish
with hot chocolate syrup if that would
kick it with some nuts maybe some gray
maybe some nuts to break it up a bit
that might be an interesting uh
alteration of it but no it's pretty
useless I'll give it a five yeah it's
been nice well it was a good story
though it was it was a sad story it's
supposed to be it's because it's also a
cautionary tale yeah you know because
you shouldn't don't judge food by your
imagination or or like like a book by
its cover yeah you know see this is the
thing this is getting back to this Lust
For Life that you've got Robert that I
enjoy I always I love it when you happen
to be so and another thing you do with
which is great and a lot of actors don't
do this is you will be very kind to
people you you'll watch TV shows or
films and you will Rave about people's
performances you Rave about a new TV
show or a new movie that you've saw
you'll drop a note saying you have to
watch this you have to watch this person
in this oh you've been reading my tweets
not even just talking to you every time
I meet you there'll be a new TV show
that you've watched and you love some
actor because Twitter is so unkind it is
I decided and I'm listen I'm a cynic but
I decided to have a snark free good for
you tweet and I also I love actors I
love them uh and I'm a fanboy and so I
try to remind my fans of things they
shouldn't Miss and one of the great
things I love about
doing film festivals and conventions as
I get to meet you guys you know and tell
you I'm what I'm a fan of yours and
other actors that I meet or I've just
you know I recently I I got to tell
Brendan Frazier
what a fan I am of his and I understand
he has a new film coming out that's just
extraordinary the whale the whale but
also uh I'd seen his the Ugly American
with Michael Kane he's brilliant in that
yeah and and several other things too
the James whale not the whale but the
James whale a Frankenstein thing he did
but but uh recently I I did stranger
things and there's a boy on that and you
may know him Joseph Quinn uh but I
watched him on a Friday in London and
there was maybe three or four t-shirts
of the hellfire club from stranger
things at the con and on Saturday there
was a hundred Hellfire t-shirts and
maybe 20 t-shirts with his image on them
and on Sunday there was probably 150
Hellfire t-shirts and about a hundred
t-shirts different t-shirts with
different images of Joseph on them as
his character Eddie Munson and I watched
him become for him I think the first
time of being a star but I and you guys
understand how difficult
his job was on that show because that
shows in its fourth season he got
dropped into it all the kids everybody
knows everybody they've all been doing
it for years now he's dropped into it he
has a certain responsibility of being
comedy relief he's also a reluctant hero
of sorts he also and when I saw it there
was something I kept going who does he
remind me of who does real and then I
realized because that show is a pay into
the 80s and I realize he's looks like
Eddie Van Halen all right you know and
uh it was such a great choice and uh I I
wanted him to know and I was able to
share with him just that actors thing of
boy I know how difficult I do the degree
of difficulty very good but he had to go
through on that show and I love doing
that yeah for other actors because when
I love it when a fan or when an actor
comes up and reminds me of some movie I
did in 1975 and some little sticker
piece of business I did or some line
delivery that I did 45 over 50 years ago
and I still remember that and they
remember like a great pool shot I did in
a master or they remember some fight
scene I had that really got and I love
getting that specific little moment that
little and I know you guys love it when
somebody just talks about some little
quiet moment absolutely you had
something that you know you don't you
just realized that 10 years later and 5
000 miles away you re that your
performance registered yes still
resonates yeah and speaking of that loss
for Life Robert you'll head into one of
the more exciting film festivals on the
planet to sit just on Tuesday you're
going to Spain I'm I'm on a plane on
Tuesday yeah so tell us a little bit
about that because you're not just
attending the festival this time
especially getting an award and I love
it because their award is so cool it's
the robot from metropolis and it was
also the uh uh the uh time machine from
the HG Wells my favorite movie Ron
Taylor oh Yvette mimio oh the Eloy very
cool love that film but uh uh uh I'm I
also have a documentary
I think it's called Hollywood Dreams and
Nightmares and it's just sort of like
I'm hoping I haven't seen it and I I'm
gonna have to see it before they screen
it there because I can't watch it with
an audience it'll be like going to your
own funeral Huckleberry Finn Tom Sawyer
you know uh when they show up at their
funeral but uh and then I'm I think
there's going to be a Sizzle read reel
for a new movie I have coming out called
Natty Knox a little a little a little
down and dirty horror movie yeah yes
with uh uh uh Danielle and you have a TV
show on just now as well I think it's
going to be all of October I think it
begins in earlier in October but I think
there's six hours maybe more and it's
great you guys are gonna like it the
compendium of horror and I narrate it
and it's on epics Channel and it's the
history of horror in in movies oh
fantastic and they've got way down deep
in the rabbit hole of the universal
archives just some extraordinary images
you've never seen before behind the
scenes stuff in the classic days of
universal as well as lots of other stuff
and I knew I was happy to do this
project when they included one of my
early science fiction movies that I
watched as a little boy after school it
was called them about the giant ants and
it has this terrific a terrific sound
effect that the ants make that you
couldn't even you couldn't improve upon
today great poster great movie yeah the
James Whitmore really James Whitmore
well it's so great to see you still
being so busy and still moving around
with you guys too we always see each
other in airports and lobbies and Lobby
bars
yeah and hopefully at some point soon at
a convention because we're doing
hopefully maybe one or two more before
the end yeah yeah film festival or
something somewhere yeah and then next
year I'll see you guys on the road again
yeah yeah all right I owe you guys a
drink yeah we're inviting me here all
right wow how about some uh carrot
sticks and uh yeah we'll bring some for
you thank you very much thanks for
having me what a wonderful chat
brilliant thank you
um great Dom where do people uh send uh
if they wanted to send a voicemail I'll
get in touch with us or something like
that where would that be you could do
that at uh the friendship on you in for
um Billy will get it right speakpike.com
forward slash the Friendship onion you
can get merchandise which is like
t-shirts and things we'll give you one
for free don't you worry about that
Robert at the Friendship
onionpodcast.com we'll see you next week
on the Friendship onion they've got cool
swag you guys it's true
foreign
[Music]